good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today we're going to learn how to stand
up for what you believe over to you
Bernie Sanders whatever you have young
people who have a passion for politics
interest potential or pursue careers in
politics and political and public
service or business parties books I
don't like the work passion for politics
what I prefer is level blowhards the
justice
I hope or soon allow the University of
Oklahoma and kids'll not the news come
on dear God I want to be personal or
discernment and that doesn't interest
more when new church is when somebody
tells me they're concerned about the
healthcare crisis in America where they
concerned about how how can they do
something a lot of good one of the races
record sake only we're raising the
minimum wage to 15 bucks an hour
happy possible realizations in silently
we're absolute a concern actually
they're partly there so I would say your
answer your question is number one gone
into your gut God jinke you got not
necessarily available what do you really
believe think that that idea not right
away what I will times he had the
courage to stand up the people who want
to reject you or priests around okay and
if you have those qualities jump in and
if politics against our consent you have
meaning for everybody our bananas they
are on Aquino really clearly broad
members or of see whole is their problem
with the episode on entire establishment
which fire away
the health of the person was a
democratic party and we didn't push that
aside we brought up
we start programs young people for all
people to win in the environment 20 oz
it was an extraordinary strength because
so much excitement so much energy it's a
lot fun but connecting to happen don't
do if you just like they're having a
career the part one said think about is
a magnet one way that you can bring
change to this world that's what you
want go for it and have the guts to
stand up and fight for what evil